Mitch McConnell raises money and he
gives it to Republican Senators and they
go out and vote very simple he's not a
leader he just raises money and he gives
it you know he pays gives him a lot of
money and it's amazing you know that
they can get that by because they needed
10 Senators 10 or 12 and he gets the 10
or 12 including himself it's a horrible
Bill do you know on the border security
we get nothing and yet we're giving four
or five countries border security for
almost 500 million dollars so they're
allowed to have border security and
we're not it's not even it's not even
possible what they're doing now remember
nobody on the left is saying we can't
have a border or border security there's
just I there's no one on the left is
saying that the point is can we fix
immigration deal with DACA actually
determine what we think we're solving
with a wall realize it won't actually
work and put in place solutions that
make sense the these are straw man
arguments on immigration